whenever i'm writing um i definitely put
my
truth in my lyrics and that's usually
why i write um is because i need to get
something out
and i was looking at your lyrics and you
can be very poetic
can i ask you about some of them and
kind of where it came from okay so
here's one
what is love love is pain love is
butterflies and stomach aches
love is looking out a window pane tears
dripping looking like you're in the rain
i mean that's so poetic where did that
come from
i mean lyrics mean different things as
you as life continues i guess i mean
like i just found love for the first
time so
that that love was actually talking
about a family love that i was
that i that i didn't have and but but
now it kind of means to me
that loving someone is how much you're
scared to lose them
wow so the like how however
that amount is that you're scared to
like live this life without this person
is really how much you love them so
wow that is wow yeah i'm gonna talk
about that in therapy next week so
um what so little big town that was
pretty awesome right i mean
you're from nashville you're country
singers you're storytellers that's
amazing
i love i love have i loved like that
like i'm like geez something that's
terrifying
um i mean exciting is what i meant to my
therapist out there
um and here's here's another um i'm
overstimulated
and i'm sad i don't expect you to
understand
i mean i feel like a lot of people
have felt like that like you know
because we're always constantly going
what does that mean to you like why'd
you write that
i mean probably what it meant to you
like when the world's eyes came on you
and people were wondering like you know
like well how could you be sad when all
of this opportunities come to you
and you know really it's like
the fact that you're over stimulated
it's like you have so much of
this these these things but they
they really don't equal out to emotional
support you know they're just like
materials yeah they're fleeting so
um and the following line is i don't
expect you to understand because it's
almost like
i think jim carrey said it he was like i
wish everyone in the world could
experience what it's like to be rich and
famous just so you can realize that it
means nothing
yeah and it's in it coming from i like
if i was my poor kid self would be like
well try me
yo yo hey me too i said the same thing
dude
me too but i've been there that's what
i'm saying like i've been completely
dirt poor and and i would have made that
joke back then
but it is true like you really do and
coming back to your
you know the poetry with the whole
statement of love from you it's like
it doesn't equal out to that it doesn't
it's all fleeting
and unless you have like solid like
valuable
like worth in your relationships it's it
doesn't it's all going to go away like
it doesn't matter
and that's coming from a kid that came
from nothing so yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
help